وكان القطاع الدوائي في لبنان قد دخل في
العامين الماضيين ازمه تنحرجه في ظل
الارتفاع الكبير في سعر صرف الدولار مقابل
الليره التي فقدت اكثر من 95% من قيمتها
ومع الغاء الحكومه اللبنانيه دعمها لدواء
فقد ارتفعت الفاتوره الاستشفائيه بشكل
كبير تجاوز 20 ضعفه
الدعم الحكوميه الذي كان يقدر ب 120 مليون
دولار انخفض الى 35 مليون يورو واقتصر
الامر على دعم الادويه المزمنه وبعض
المستلزمات الطبيه وفقا لنقابيين صحيين
فقد ادى شحه الادويه الى انتعاش عمليات
تهريب الادويه البديله من الخارج ما اتى
دخول ادميه المزوره او دون المواصفات
ويقول القائمون على قطاع الدواء في لبنان
ان الاموال التي خصصتها الحكومه اخيرا
لشراء اصناف من الادويه سرطانيه منها لا
اكثر من 40% من الحاجه يضافوا الى ذلك ان
المستشفيات الخاصه اضطرت نتيجه الازمه الى
تخفيض عدد الاسره لديها بنسبه تتراوح بين
30 الى 40% تقريبا
من بيروت سينظموا الينا مراسل الجزيره
جونيس جوني يعني للاسف قطعه الدواء في
لبنان يؤدي الثمن مشهد قاتم يدفع ثمنه
المواطن اللبناني من صحته
صحيح عبد الصمد هي ازمه متشعبه لها الكثير
من التداعيات والارتدادات مرتبطه بعدم
توفر الاعتمادات اللازمه من اجل استيراد
ما يكفي من الادويه مرتبطه بالادويه
المزوره وايضا مرتبطه بالازمه السياسيه في
البلاد التي تمنع الحكومه من انعقاد نحن
امام احد اكبر الصيدليات في بيروت سندخل
اليها للحديث مع بعض المسؤولين هنا عن
تداعيات هذه الازمه وعن كيفيه التعامل
الصيدليات وايضا كيفيه تعامل المواطنين مع
ازمه الادويه المزمنه وادويه الامراض
السرطانيه هناك طبعا معاناه كبيره يتحدث
عنها المواطنون يتحدث عنها المعنيون بهذا
القطاع بشان توفر الادويه همم سنتحدث الى
المسؤوله في الصيدليه الدكتوره ماجده كوزي
عن هذه القضيه
لنتوقف عند كامل اعتداعيات المرتبطه بها
دكتوره ماجده طبعا هناك ازمه كبيره بشان
ادويه الامراض المزمنه وامراض السرطان كيف
تتعاملون معها كيف تلمسون معاناه
المواطنين في هذا السياط
كثير عم يتعذب نحن بتعرف المريض عنده شقه
لا الدواء وشق نفسيا فهو صار عنده اللمعه
من الدواء وصار في عليها ثاني انه عم
يتعذب ليلى وما عم بيكون في مصدر موثوق
فيه يعني
يكون مصدر
المريض يجيبه من بره ويمكن يطلع الدواء
مزوره احنا نطلب من وزاره الصحه ده
هتكونوا موجودين حتى يكون عم ياخذ الدواء
الدواء الاساسي
مسحته الى اي مدى كالموصون معاناه الناس
يوميا من خلال التعاطي معهم من خلال طلبات
المواطنين الذين ياتون الى الصيدليه يوميا
يوميا نلمس معاناه المرضى المرضى كثير عم
يتعذبوا
عم بيصير في كثير ازمه كبيره ما عم يلاقي
ابدا دوا عم يتاخر علاجاته يعني مريض
الكانسر عنده كيما صار فيه بده ياخذ على
العلاج عم يضطر ياجده اول مره والثاني مره
وثالث مره هذا يؤثر على على العلاج بشكل
كامل
يعني كل معوض على دوام ياخذ هالدواء له
فتره
همم
شكرا لك على هذه الاضاءه عبد الصمد
النقابات التي شاركت ان الازمه السياسيه
في البلاد واستمرار الانسداد السياسي في
البلاد وعدم انعقاد جلسات الحكومه حكومه
تصريف الاعمال من اجل تسيير شؤون
المواطنين سينعكس سلبا وسيزيد هذه الازمه
تعقيدا ويدفع
هذه الازمه في المقام الاول المرضى
والمواطنون اللبنانيون علما ان وزاره
الصحه كانت امنت في الاشهر الماضيه او
الشهر الماضي على وجه التحديد اعتمادات
ماليه ولكنها تكفي فقط لتامين حاجات نصف
المرضى همم الذين يطالبون بتلقي علاجهم
اشكرك جوني طونيوس مراسيل الجزيره في
بيروت شكرا لك